France elected Emmanuel macron as their
new president over over far right
candidate marine lepen but this is
interesting many French voters were
dissatisfied with both candidates and in
France voters are always given the
option to simply vote nobody on their
ballots they have that option yeah well
this election this is amazing over four
million French voters did just that and
voted for nobody yes nobody highest in
half a century
now what most people don't know is that
nobody is an actual living person this
is the closest he's ever come to winning
in France
we've got him via satellite I think to
talk about the election results please
welcome via Paris nobody let's see if we
can find him you there oh thank you
thank you for joining us Monsieur
nobody how are you Oh am i how is anyone
we are all dancing toward the grave so
I'm sorry who are you and what exactly
do you stand for I am nobody I stand for
nasty well I'm sorry four million people
voted for you this election a vote
meaningless a vote is but a whisper in
an empty stadium in fact that was my
official campaign slogan we had it
printed on hats oh you had it on hats oh
that's nice
it's not really a catchy slogan what
what does it matter
just as the bee stings knowing it will
only hasten its own demise we all
shuffle through the darkened corridors
of life's senselessness they agree but I
think I personally think that's very
depressing well it's all right there in
my campaign ad regard there was nothing
there is nothing there will always be
nothing to vote is to die I am nobody in
this message means nothing to me
so it's true you you really do believe
in nothing at all correct a vote for
nobody is a vote for nothing for I
believe in nothing except a mandatory
subsidized school lunch program more
whole grains less sugar you know thank
you very much children are our most
precious yeah
[Applause]
you